hi arms are P do biz and I'll it I'm 14
years old and I live in the great state
of Wyoming now as you can see behind me
this is the grays river which is Wyoming
longest unde and river now there's all
kinds of things to do here for those are
like fishing you found the right spot
the grays river is really known for its
cutthroat trout and if you go upstream
you'll go to the Triborough basin where
all where you'll find all three
subspecies have cut tho Chau in this
part of the United States now there's
all car there's also other stuff to do
here like mountain bike riding hiking
bird watching animal watching like up
there here sometimes you can see elk up
there now besides that there are also
several ones really famous for all this
there are several national forests in
lines such as the Shoshone National
Forest which is why it which is the
world's first national boards there is
the bridger-teton Force which is what
I'm standing in right now there is also
the targian national force which is
right over those neurons over there and
there is also the bighorn national
forest the Black Hills National Forest
the Wasatch National Forest the Ashley
natural course we got several there is
also several national parks there's the
Yellowstone National Park the world's
first national park grand teton national
park which is really famous for the
views of the Grand Tetons there's devils
tower national monument which was the
first national are meant to be settled
in the world
which was established in 1906 there's
also fossil Butte national mommy which
is about kind of like 60 miles down and
his famous quotes fossils it's not
greedy up what does green mean to you
and your friends green means to me my
friends green like renewable energy like
wind solar ocean high power seems like
that what's why only some of the things
Wyoming's contributing to Y all means
most top renewable resource right now is
win and if you don't know this Wyoming
is one of the windiest states in the
nation so hold your half and you come
here how about clean air how do we ring
we ranked second as to one of the
cleanest air in the whole United States
second only to North Dakota if you're
going to change the world let's say
you're you're put in charge of the world
but one day what would you do to make
the world
I would try to establish peace like the
Middle East it seems like war never
stops there like this ones are like
trying to take over Israel and
everything's and there's always religion
tension in other parts of the world I
would try to help get me looking settled
and there is a no-go so try help the
world get more energy efficient like
right now we use so much oil coal and
natural gas that it could like be gone
just like 60 or 80 or close to 200 years
and so we should go to be more energy
efficient about what we heroes Zachary
number one you almost tried to cross
this river and almost ground never try
and cross this river you'll feel your
that current will just take you right
down well what what what else she gonna
say now to bring people to this state
what would you say what what would you
say well let me say if you ever come
here the cowboy state welcomes you
you